but your Christmas special airs tonight
on ABC right yeah and it's are you
excited I love I love doing Christmas
specials look at all that Talent on this
stage oh it's great it's a great show I
I was able to put in some of the hits
and the Christmas uh songs and you don't
even know what which one is coming and
it's I like that yeah oh that's really
cool to do because people always want
yeah they always want to hear like the
hits as well so that's really smart I'm
I'm not that smart I've never done that
um but we heard that they wouldn't let
you have puppies that you wanted puppies
well yeah how did you know that they
didn't I know well I like puppies I've
got everything it snows on the on the
audience and there's presents and
there's trees and I thought and little
children the little kids are come
running out and Santa Claus mag
everything so he had everything and I
said Gee wouldn't it be great if we had
like a puppy for one of the little kids
wouldn't it be great let's bring Barry a
puppy he didn't get a puppy we've got
puppies look at these two cute
puppies
oh my God can I hold one oh my goodness
this is
spot oh how
old goodness hello oh my
goodness what's your name oh you Barry
this is dangerous I do not need another
dog oh my God everybody I should mention
these puppies are spot and Tiny from the
brixies rescue center and you can find
out how you can adopt them or their
Friends by heading to our show's
Instagram stories you're
sweet hello hello I you recognizes she
did she was like favorite Mandy is her
favorite you're trying to get to my
coffee bro
no um I hear that you um actually ended
up breaking Elvis's record in Vegas with
the most live shows right that was great
it was an honor it really was an honor
cuz anytime people think of Vegas you
think of Elvis and all those live shows
and you have trumped him I like it yeah
and you know on that day I sang hound
dog oh did you me singing hound dog why
not and I jiggled around a little bit
like yeah I like it you got to jiggle a
little it's Elvis oh they're like crying
do you want to go run around maybe they
want to run around I don't know do you
want down or do you want do you want
down you want to go we going to let him
down let him free let him be free okay
okay ready here we go ready run go have
fun they're going to be peeing all over
this place this way
ready PE yeah go they're like this is
mine this is mine um so while they're
marking their territory oh my God
they're so cute I really don't need
another dog
[Music]
[Applause]
Barry thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home oh